[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Dunja
Hayali schönen guten Abend das
Kriegsrecht verlängert die Mobilmachung
geht auch weiter zudem soll der
ukrainische Geheimdienst einen
russischen Spionagering ausgehoben und
fünf Verdächtige festgenommen haben die
Ukraine tut was sie kann um sich gegen
die Übernahme durch Russland zu wehren
länger sicherlich als viele es für
möglich gehalten haben aber in einer
besonders guten Lage ist das Land
aktuell nicht es fehlt an
Artilleriegranaten an Munition an
Ersatzteilen und auch an ausgeruhten
Soldaten hinzu kommt auch noch der
anhaltende innenpolitische Zwist
zwischen dem Präsidenten und dem
Militärchef Anne
Brühl mehr Symbolik geht kaum der
Präsident im gepanzerten Fahrzeug an
vorderster Front bei robotine da wo es
wirklich gefährlich ist
ihr seid unsere Kämpfer und führt solch
eine wichtige Mission aus den Feind zu
schlagen und den Krieg zu gewinnen ich
wünsche euch dass der Sieg
gelingt motivieren kommunizieren das
Land zusammenhalten das war mal die
Stärke von selenski gerade ist er dabei
das zu
verspielen denke ich über einen Neustart
nach wenn wir über einen Neustart
sprechen dann sprechen wir über den
Austausch einer Reihe von
Führungspersönlichkeiten in unserem
Land dabei geht es vor allem um ihn den
Oberkommandierenden der Streitkräfte
general zuschni muss er gehen oder nicht
es ist ein Rauswurf auf Raten dabei ist
zuschni populär gerade bei seinen
Soldaten es kommf an wer ih ersetzen
wird aberell haben wir kein Problem mit
ihm wenn unsere Regierung jemand
auswechseln möchte dann sollte ein
solcher Wechsel die Dinge verbessern
nicht verschlechtern daran sollten Sie
denken es ist ein Machtkampf der längst
zum Politikum geworden ist im ZDF
Interview war kievs Bürgermeister klitko
vor
Eskalation was befindet sich in Krieg
das ist eine riesige große fle für jede
Politiker gibt kein Sinn ein zu machen
zum eine Position zu kämpfen weil heute
die Frage steht ganz scharf wird
Überlebende Krieg oder nicht wir Ex
nicht die schlechten Nachrichten mehren
sich die Russen scheinen im Osten wie
hier infk überlegen viel mehr Soldaten
viel mehr Waffen an den Sieg glauben wie
selenski das fordert das fällt da schwer
kriegsmüde es ist ein wor dast in
diesen der Krieg betrifft das ganze Land
jeder Mann der hier lebt muss
dadurchgehen das ist unumkehrbar die
Leute hier sind einfach
müde fast zi Jahre Krieg fordern ihr
Tribut mit veralteten Waffen ohne
Unterstützung westlicher Partner ist
dieser Krieg für die Ukraine nicht zu
gewinnen die Ukraine braucht also
Geschlossenheit Waffen Munition
Ersatzteile und auch weiterhin
finanzielle Unterstützung auch aus den
USA doch dort blockieren die
Republikaner schon länger ein
Gesetzespaket in dem auch die Ukraine
Hilfe inkludiert ist der Präsident Joe
Biden hat daher das Paket in dem immer
mehrere Vorhaben verhandelt werden noch
mal aufgeschnürt und in Absprache mit
Republikanern schärfere
gesetzessicherung und eine
Grenzsicherung und eine härtere
Einwanderungspolitik mit reingepackt
also alles paletti mit nichten denn die
Verhandler haben die Rechnung ohne
Donald Trump gemacht nicht der einzige
Grund warum dieser heute für
Schlagzeilen sorgt aus Washington
Benjamin
Daniel mit ukrainanstecker am rev tritt
der US-Präsident vor wenigen Stunden ans
Rednerpult wild entschlossen für die
Gesetzesvorlage zu
kämpfen es geht hierbei um noch mehr als
die Ukraine wenn wir Putins Machthunger
nicht stoppen wird er sich nicht auf die
ukra
en dann werden noch viel höhere Kosten
auf Amerika und unsere Verbündeten
zukommen verantwortlich dafür wären die
Republikaner im Kongress die das Gesetz
blockieren die Geschichte schaut
zu die geplante Maßnahme umfasst
insgesamt 118 Milliarden Dollar darin
enthalten unter anderem 20 Milliarden
Dollar für eine bessere Sicherung der
Grenze zu Mexiko und 60 Milliarden
Dollar für die Ukraine im Ringen um das
Paket sind die Demokraten den
Republikanern bereits mit weitreichenden
Zugeständnissen in Sachen Grenzsicherung
entgegengekommen für einige Demokraten
zu weit für die meisten Republikaner
hingegen nicht weit
genug die Vorlage ist es nicht wert dass
wir uns damit befassen sie wäre in dem
Moment vom Tisch in dem Sie hier ankommt
die Republikaner sind nicht an einer
Lösung des migrationsproblems
interessiert wir schon und wir können
das auf eine viel humanere Weise
schaffen mit einem Gesetz dass sich
wirklich mit den befasst auf dies
ankommt der Vorwurf die Republikaner
sein nicht an einer Lösung der
Grenzprobleme interessiert ist nicht
ganz abwegig schließlich geht es um
eines von Trumps Topthemen der
Ex-Präsident muss zur Zeit ohnehin fast
täglich Dämpfer einstecken heute
beispielsweise lehnte ein Gericht sein
Gesuch auf Immunität ab er kann also
wegen seinem Versuch die Wahl 2020 zu
kippen angeklagt werden eine Einigung im
Grenzstreit würde ihm zusätzlich Wind
aus den wahlkampfsegeln nehmen und so
tut er alles dafür die Vorlage zu
torpedieren sollte sie am Ende
tatsächlich Scheitern wäre das das aus
der US
ukrainehilfe dem Präsidenten bleiben
wenig Optionen es gibt geringe Mittel im
Pentagon ETA für
verteidigungskooperation die aber weitem
nicht die 60 Milliarden Dollar die
etatisiert waren im Nachtragshaushalt
aufwiegen können die einzige
realistische Option ist das eingefrorene
Auslandsvermögen russischer Oligarchen
anzugehen DAV liegen aber die große
Mehrzahl der 300 Milliarden Dollar in
Europa und es wird eine Diskussion geben
auch verstärkt nach den Geschehnissen
hier in Washington mit den europäischen
Partnern wie man an dieses Geld
herankommen kann sollte der Deal am Ende
tatsächlich Scheitern wäre es also ein
schwerer Rückschlag für die Demokraten
im Kongress für den
US-Präsidenten und vor allem für die
Ukraine Fragen dazu jetzt an Professor
für internationale an der
bundeswehruniversität in München einen
schönen guten Abend schönen guten Abend
Frau her Herr Professor ohne die
Unterstützung der USA kann die Ukraine
diesen Verteidigungskrieg dann noch
gewinnen also wenn die wenn die
ausbleibende Unterstützung der USA nicht
durch die Europäer aufgefangen wird dann
wird es für die Ukraine sehr sehr schwer
das muss man ganz einfach so sagen und
die Frage ist auch werden die Europäer
überhaupt in der Lage sein und sind sie
willend diese ausbleibende Unterstützung
aufzufangen wenn sie sagen sind Sie in
der Lage und auch
willillens wie ist denn da ihre
Einschätzung na ja es ist so dass äh
Olaf Scholz hat ja gemeinsam mit vier
anderen Ministerpräsidenten einen
Artikel in der Financial Times verfas
inem man die Europäer dazu auffordert
mehr zu tun
es gibt Diskussionen in der Europäischen
Union wie man das machen könnte aber
letztenendes ist es so die Europäische
Union ist da nicht geeint also sie ist
einfach in der Überzeugung man müsste
mehr für die Ukraine tun nicht geeint es
gibt ein ein eine zweispaltung wenn Sie
so wollen zwischen den Staaten Mittel
und Osteuropa baltischen Staaten
nordischen Staaten die Willens und
entschlossen sind hier noch mehr
finanzielle Hilfe an den Tag zu legen
und es gibt Staaten die eher
zurückhaltenend sind die findet man eher
im Süden also das sind Italien Spanien
Portugal und zum Teil auch Frankreich
von daher gibt es keine einheitliche
Position in Europa gerade über diese
Frage aber bräuchte es dann eine Allianz
der Willigen und die die dann wirklich
wollen müssten dann auch über das hinaas
über das Maß hinaus produzieren und auch
Zahlen es braucht eine Allianz der
Willigen die bereit ist einen gewissen
Anteil ihres Verteidigungsbudgets über
einen längeren Zeitraum ausschließlich
der ukraineehilfe zur Verfügung zu
stellen das wäre ein Weg aus aus diesem
aus dieser Malaise in der sich die
Europäische Union gerade befindet oder
es braucht eine Idee wie man innerhalb
der Europäischen Union ähm diese Aufgabe
gemeinsam übernimmt aber es muss
sozusagen jetzt Bewegung da reinkommen
weil ansonsten sind wir in einer Phase
und wir sehen das ja schon auf dem
Schlachtfeld in der ukra Ukraine in dem
ganz einfach die wichtigsten Sachen für
Kriegsführung und das ist nun mal
Munition Artilleriegranaten in dem die
fehlen die entscheidende Militärhilfe
kommt halt im Moment noch aus den USA
wie schätzen sie denn überhaupt die
Situation aktuell ein in der
Ukraine es ist für die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte das hat ihr Bericht ja auch
angedeutet extrem schwierig vor allen
Dingen im Osten wo die russische Armee
Mann und Material an die Front schmeißt
um Städte zu erobern die Ukrainer haben
da bislang sehr Erfolg ich dagegen
gehalten also die russischen
territorialen Gewinne sind minimal
gewesen aber mit der ausbleibenden
Munition und natürlich auch mit den
ukrainischen Verlusten dreht sich
langsam das Blatt und es ist nicht
auszuschließen dass die Ukraine in den
nächsten Wochen einige dieser Städte
aufgeben muss weil es sozusagen aus
ihrer Perspektive die Verluste die sie
dort erleidet ganz einfach die Verluste
den sie der russischen Armee zufügt
nicht aufwiegenm also ohne Material und
ohne Mensch also ohne Soldaten kann man
natürlich auch keinen Krieg gewinnen wer
oder was kann denn der Ukraine jetzt
helfen und damit ist nicht unbedingt nur
die Frage nach Taurus jetzt gemeint nein
also solche Fragen wie nach Taurus sind
wichtig aber sie sind momentan nicht die
wichtigste Sache die die Ukraine braucht
die Ukraine braucht das wurde in ihrem
Bericht ja schon gesagt sie braucht
artilleriesysteme sie braucht Munition
Artilleriegranaten sie braucht
Ersatzteile das ist im Schwerpunkt im im
Donbass ein artilleriekrieg und wer dort
über genügend Systeme und genügend
Munition verfügt hat die möglich
dort Gewinne zu erzielen oder bzw den
Angreifer abzuwehren und wenn das nicht
kommt und da sind wir leider Gottes viel
zu spät also ich würde mal behaupten
selbst wenn morgen eine Einigung erzielt
werden würde in Europa dann würde es
noch Monate dauern bis diese Munition
dann wirklich zur Verfügung stehen würde
und das ist die kritische Zeit die die
Ukraine überbrücken muss und deshalb ist
die Situation momentan so kritisch für
die Ukraine aber dieses wir sind zu spät
hören wir ja nun auch seit Wochen und
Monaten wann immer wir über
verschiedenes Material gesprochen haben
wie kann das sein vor allen Dingen wir
haben ja gerade den US-Präsidenten auch
gehört und auch der
Verteidigungsminister sagt wir müssen
uns vorbereiten
wer weiß was die Russen noch so Plan und
wenn sie die Ukraine dann doch besiegen
sollten wer weiß wohin der kriüeg dann
der Krieg dann noch führen wird also
wieso ist es immer alles zu spät na ich
glaube wenn man lange Zeit in Washington
und auch in Berlin äh sich nicht darüber
im Klaren war was man da eigentlich will
also will man dass die Ukraine sich
verteidigen kann oder will man dass die
Ukraine Russland besiegen kann dann
haben wir immer nur reagiert wenn die
Situation wirklich kritisch wurde für
die Ukraine und sie sehen das ja auch
jetzt also die Situation ist kritisch
jetzt kommt plötzlich Bewegung rein wir
haben letztenendes nie eine klare
Strategie gehabt was wir dort eigentlich
mit der Unterstützung erreichen wollen
oder bzw wir haben lange Zeit sozusagen
darauf gesetzt dass die Ukraine sich nur
verteidigen kann und das Recht sich
jetzt nun man hätte diesen ganzen
Prozess schon vor anderthalb Jahren
beginnen müssen der war abzusehen und
das hat man nicht gemacht aus
politischen Gründen sonst hätte man man
eben volle Kraft voraus möglicherweise
gestartet oder diesen Weg eingeschlagen
jetzt hat der Bundeskanzler angekündigt
die heimische Industrie hochzufahren
weil Europa bei der munitionsherstellung
seine Ziele verfehlt bis März sollte
eigentlich eine Million
Artilleriegeschosse geliefert werden man
schafft möglicherweise die Hälfte wie
kann man sich denn so verkalkulieren
oder
verrechnen na ja ich glaube es gab ja
schon damals die kritischen Stimmen die
gesagt haben diese äh diese Verkündung
der eine Million Schuss das war von
Anfang an unrealistisch weil ganz
einfach das Verhältnis zwischen Staaten
und Industrie noch nicht klar geregelt
war das war eher eine prnummer und die
ist dann den Europäern böse auf die Füße
gefallen und jetzt sind wir halt in der
Situation in der wir sind jetzt versucht
es der Bundeskanzler mit der heimischen
Produktion aber Sie müssen sich ganz
einfach auch vor Augen halten damit man
die malais ganz einfach mal sieht vor
ein paar Wochen waren die wichtigsten
munitionslieferanten sowohl für Russland
als auch für die Ukraine Südkorea und
Nordkorea nicht die europäischen Staaten
für die Ukraine und nicht die USA für
die Ukraine und ob das mit dem
produzierend in Deutschland so
funktioniert und auch so schnell und in
der Anzahl ist ja auch noch mehr als
fraglich also wie sicher also was auch
sicher ist was nicht hilfreich ist ist
natürlich noch mal in die Ukraine jetzt
geblickt der Streit zwischen dem
Präsidenten und dem Militärchef wie
schätzen Sie das
ein also das zwischen diesen beiden ein
ein angespanntes Verhältnis ist das
wissen wir schon seit langem
nun ist es nichts Ungewöhnliches ich sag
jetzt mal den Generalstabschef zu
entlassen während eines laufenden
Krieges allerdings muss man sagen dass
man kann saluschnin jetzt nicht
katastrophale militärische Fehler
vorwerfen deswegen ist diese Entlassung
kommt zu einem unpassenden Zeitpunkt die
Situation ist kritisch der Mann ist wie
ihr Bericht ja auch zeigt hat in den
Streitkräften beliebt er ist in der
Bevölkerung der Ukraine beliebter nach
allen Umfragen als selenski das bringt
alles nur Unruhe rein die die Ukraine
jetzt gerade nicht gebrauchen kann und
der Versuch so eine Art Befreiungsschlag
zu machen wie selenski in diesem
Interview ja auch angedeutet hat sagt ja
nicht unbedingt dass damit eine bessere
militärische Strategie einhergehen wird
weil ganz einfach es fehlen die
fundamentalen Voraussetzungen um die
Operationsführung weiterzuführen im
Osten und wenn man die Köpfe auswechselt
schafft man tatsächlich auch keine neue
Lage Herr Professor vielen herzlichen
Dank für Ihre Einschätzung heute abend
ich danke
Ihnen und wir machen jetzt erstmal
weiter mit den Nachrichten und mit dir
Hanna im Kampf gegen die Klimakrise hat
die EU-Kommission ein neues Ziel
ausgerufen bis 2040 sollen die CO2
Emissionen um 90% reduziert werden
verglichen mit
1990 das neue Etappenziel soll helfen in
der EU bis 2050 Klimaneutralität zu
erreichen als Sektoren die Treibhausgase
einsparen können werden unter anderem
industrieverkehr und Landwirtschaft
genannt zudem sieht der Vorschlag vor
erneuerbare Energien auszubauen und CO2
im Boden zu Speich was durchaus
umstritten ist wir bleiben in Straßburg
das EU-Parlament hat nämlich heute dafür
gestimmt dass Fahrverbote künftig
EU-weit durchgesetzt werden sollen wird
die Fahrerlaubnis entzogen soll die
Information darüber in Zukunft unter den
Mitgliedstaaten ausgetauscht werden noch
müssen allerdings die EU-Staaten der
Reform
zustimmen Deutschland wird dem von der
EU geplanten lieferkettengesetz am
Freitag nicht zustimmen sondern sich
halten das hat Bundesarbeitsminister
Heil heute angekündigt und die FDP dafür
verantwortlich gemacht Heil sprach von
einer Blockade der Freidemokraten die
ideologisch motiviert sei eine
Enthaltung Deutschlands könnte das
gesamte Vorhaben scheitern lassen das
Gesetz soll unter anderem Kinder und
Zwangsarbeit bekämpfen die FDP
befürchtet durch das Vorhaben Nachteile
für die deutsche
Wirtschaft das Bundesamt für
Verfassungsschutz darf die AFD
Organisation junge Alternative als
gesichert rechtsextremistisch einstufen
das hat das Verwaltungsgericht Köln
entschieden und damit eine Klage von AFD
und J abgelehnt zur Begründung erklärte
das Gericht dass sich Anhaltspunkte für
verfassungsfeindliche Bestrebungen der
jungen Alternative zur Gewissheit
verdichtet hätten der Beschluss ist noch
nichts
rechtskräftig Deutschland soll besser
vor Cyberangriffen geschützt werden mit
einem neuen nationalen it Lagezentrum
des Bundesamts für Sicherheit in der
Informationstechnik heute wurde die
Einrichtung in Bonn von
bundesinnenministerin fäer eröffnet
Spezialisten unterschiedlicher
Fachrichtungen sollen dort rund um die
Uhr die cybersicherheitslage für
Deutschland im Blick behalten und
Informationen mit anderen nationalen und
internationalen Akteuren
austauschen die einen sind
eingeschüchtert und befürchten tionen
die anderen boyottieren die Wahl weil es
eh keine fre sei den jetzigen
Präsidenten Aserbaidschans wird das
alles wenig kümmern er will bei der
morgen stattfindenden
Präsidentschaftswahl seine Macht
festigen 6 Millionen Menschen sind
aufgerufen ihre Stimme abzugeben außer
denen die sich kritisch gegen den
autoritären Präsidenten geäußert haben
einige von denen haben keine Stimme mehr
einfach weil sie im Gefängnis sitzen
insbesondere Journalisten wie Sebastian
berichtet das sind die letzten Aufnahmen
von Sevin wagif Gisi kurze Zeit später
wird die regierungskritische
Journalistin in Baku verhaftet seit Ende
November sitzt sie im Gefängnis wir
treffen ihre Mutter OP felia in der
aserbaidschanischen Hauptstadt sie hat
ihre Tochter seit über zwei Monaten
nicht gesehen konnte ihr nicht mal
Kleidung
bringen ich kann sie weder anrufen noch
sie treffen ich mache mir große Sorgen
ich weiß nicht wie es geh ich erfahre
das nur über unseren Anwalt er sagt sie
ist körperlich sehr schwach und kann
kaum
essen aeridsans Präsident ilam alieev
zieht die Daumenschrauben im Land an ze
Journalisten wurden seit Ende November
verhaftet niemand soll vor den Wahlen
seine Macht gefährden der
aserbaidschanische Menschenrechtler Arif
junus kennt das Regime al er saß vor 10
Jahren selbst in einem Gefängnis in Baku
heute lebt in Holland und beobachtet die
Entwicklungen in seiner Heimat mit
großer
Sorge will der Welt mit den Wahlen
zeigen dass Aserbaidschan ein
demokratisches Land ist aber in
Wirklichkeit ist die Situation der
Menschenrechte während der Herrschaft
von ilam Alev schrecklich vor allem
jetzt es kommt fast jeden Tag zu
Verhaftungen im Moment kann al sich das
erlauben den nach der Rückeroberung von
Bergkarabach ist der so populär wie nie
und auf dem Gipfel seiner Macht
außenpolitisch treibt aliev Armenien
weiter vor sich her mit aggressiven
Äußerungen schürt er im Nachbarland
Angst vor einem neuen Krieg denn er will
das Kernland Aserbaidschan mit der
exsklav nachitchewan über einen Korridor
verbinden damit hätte auch der engste
Verbündete Bakus die Türkei einen
direkten Weg ans Kaspische Meer große
Pläne bei denen der Autokrat keine
Kritik gebrauchen kann vor allem keine
Recherchen zu Korruptionen der Präsident
famie in Baku interviewen wir den
engsten Berater alievs er weiß alle
Vorwürfe von sich die Journalisten sein
wegen ihrer regimkritischen Haltung
festgenommen
worden die Institutionen die behaupten
sie würden zu Korruption recherchieren
waren selbst in Korruption verwickelt
bestimmte Medien erhielten 300 000
USDollar über illegale geldwäsch
kananäle für ihre Operation in
Aserbeidschan
usllars morgen also die
Präsidentschaftswahl dass ilam malieev
diese überdeutlich gewinnen wird
bezweifelt hier niemand einen richtigen
Wahlkampf gab es nicht die Opposition
boyottiert mehrheitlich die Wahl Ophelia
wird nicht wählen gehen seit der
Verhaftung von svinch hat sich ihr
Gesundheitszustand stark verschlechtert
ihr einziger Wunsch ist dass ihre
Tochter bald
freikommt hört jemand unsere Stimmen ein
Satz der sich in das Gedächtnis der
Überlebenden eingebrannt hat die Retter
hatten ihn tagelang gerufen als sie nach
Verschütteten gesucht haben heute ein
Jahr nach den katastrophalen Erdbeben in
Syrien und der Türkei wurde er
wiedergerufen von denen die sich von der
Politik alleinelassen fühlen die
Versprechen schnell zu helfen und den
Wiederaufbau anzutreiben haben die
Menschen unter den Trümmern ihrer
Zukunft begraben aus antakia eine der am
schwersten getroffenen Städte berichtet
Jörg
Brase Fatma Kod und ihr Mann trauern um
ihre Tochter in und die zwei Enkel sie
wurden unter den Trümmern ihres Hauses
begraben hunderte liegen hier auf diesem
Friedhof in antakia und alle haben
denselben Todestag den 6 Februar
2023 nichts hat sich vor uns verbessert
es geht uns überhaupt nicht
gut es ist noch wie vor einem Jahr
schöne Tochter ist
[Musik]
fortgegangen am Morgen um 4:17 Uhr dem
Zeitpunkt des ersten Bebens vor einem
Jahr versammeln sich Tausende in der
Innenstadt antakias um zu erinnern um zu
trauern dann aber tauchen Politiker und
offizielle auf wie der
Gesundheitsminister oder der
provinzbürgermeister tretet alle zurück
schreien sie wir wollen euch nicht hören
Wut bricht sich bah ihr habt uns im
Stich gelassen damals wie
heute es hat geregnet es war kalt von
überallen kamen Schreie und es ist jetzt
ein Jahr lang her und antakia ist immer
noch nicht aufgebaut wir leben immer
noch in Containern wir leben immer noch
in
Zelten die Regierung streitet ab dass es
solche zeltunterkünfte noch gibt doch
diese Bilder zeigen das
Gegenteil wenn wir das Zelt nicht hätten
was würden wir dann tun ich war Mieter
das Haus ist eingestürzt wir mussten uns
so ein Zelt bauen
keine Ahnung wie es jetzt weitergehen
soll der Präsident ist zur Zeit auf
Werbetour durchs Erdbebengebiet
verkündet die Erfolge seiner Regierung
verteilt Schlüssel neugebauter Wohnungen
an
Erdbebenopfer vom Versprechen nach der
Katastrophe 300.000 Häuser sofort wieder
aufzubauen sind 200.000 Wohnungen bis
Ende dieses Jahres geblieben statt
weiterer unerreichbarer Ziele nationales
Patos nur wenige Länder und
Gesellschaften die angesichts einer
solchen Katastrophe so standhaft bleiben
können wie wir in der Altstadt an takias
wird derweil noch immer der Schutt
geräumt ein paar Häuser stehen noch wie
der Laden von Schuster Ahmed KI auch er
habe sich um eine neue Wohnung beworben
sagt er habe aber noch keine bekommen
stattdessen drohe ihm hier der
Rauswurf dieser Stadtteil wird
abgerissen mein Laden auch die Behörden
haben mir 15 Tage Zeit gegeben um bis
jetzt habe ich nichts gehört sie geben
mir wohl einen containerladen heißt
es wann und wo das passieren wird und ob
überhaupt das weiß er nicht vieles ist
ungewiss hier in antakia auch ein Jahr
nach der
Katastrophe und wir machen jetzt weiter
mit Nachrichten aus der wirtschaftanner
und die sind erstmal nicht so gut das
deutsche Traditionsunternehmen miele hat
heute angekündigt weltweit bis zu 2700
Stellen abzubauen en oder zu verlagern
betroffen ist davon auch das Stammwerk
in Gütersloh Stephanie Barrett was ist
genau geplant und was sind die Gründe
für das Sparprogramm ja ausgerechnet im
Jubiläumsjahr seines 125-jährigen
Bestehens verordnet sich Miele ein
Sparprogramm das sich gewaschen hat nach
drei starken Jahren ist die Nachfrage
nach Haushaltsgeräten massiv
eingebrochen darauf reagiert der
Familienkonzern nun mit einer deutlichen
Kostensenkung auch beim Personal
streicht stellen und verlagert
schrittweise die Montage seiner
Waschmaschinen vom Stammsitz Gütersloh
nach Polen 700 Mitarbeiter sind davon
betroffen weltweit sollen weitere 2000
der mehr als 23 000 Arbeitsplätze
wegfallen allein in Deutschland
beschäftigt Miele noch rund 12000
Menschen nicht nur die weltweite Flaute
bei Haushaltsgeräten macht den
güterslohan zu schaffen auch hohe
Material und Energiekosten sorgen dafür
dass sich der Konzern vor allem im
Wettbewerb mit den asiatischen
Herstellern zunehmend schwer tut steht
Miele damit auch exemplarisch für andere
Unternehmen in Deutschland die gerade
Stellen abbauen klares Ja ob BASF Bosch
oder gerade auch der Automobilzulieferer
ZF Friedrichshafen der massiven
Stellenabbau plant sie alle ein die
Erkenntnis dass der Standort Deutschland
für Industrieproduktion einfach zu teuer
ist nicht nur wegen hoher Löhne und
steuern sondern weil auch Energie in
Deutschland auf Dauer selbst wenn sie
erneuerbar ist teuer bleiben wird
Markus miele hat kürzlich im Interview
klare Worte gefunden wenn ein Standort
in allem teuer ist dann wird es
schwierig im Kontrast zur drübtimmung in
der Wirtschaft läuft es am Aktienmarkt
der DAX erklimmt heute ein neues
Allzeithoch deutlich über 17 000 Punkten
vielen Dank Stefanie für deine
Einschätzung die lockführergewerkschaft
GDL hat einen Tarifabschluss erzielt
allerdings nicht mit der Deutschen Bahn
sondern mit Transdev dem zweitgrößten
eisenb bnunternehmen in Deutschland der
Tarifvertrag beinhaltet neben
Lohnerhöhungen und
inflationsausgleichsprämie auch eine
schrittweise Absenkung der Arbeitszeit
für Schichtarbeiter bis 2028 soll diese
bei vollem Lohn auf 35 Stunden pro Woche
sinken letzteres ist auch einer der
größten Streitpunkte in den
Tarifverhandlungen zwischen GDL und
deutscher
Bahn
427 000 Stunden so viel Stau gab es im
vergangenen Jahr in Deutschland das ist
deutlich mehr als 2022 und zwar ein Plus
von fast 100.000 Stunden zu diesem
Ergebnis kommt die staubilanz des
Automobilclubs ADAC dennoch das rohe
stauniveau vor der coronapandemie ist
noch nicht erreicht Mittwoch und
Donnerstag sind übrigens die
staureichsten Wochentage am meisten
Geduld müssen die Autofahrer in
Nordrhein-Westfalen mitbringen gefolgt
von Bayern und
Baden-Württemberg und hier folgt jetzt
37° in der Sendung geht es um junge
Menschen die sich bewusst dazu
entschieden haben eine Berufsausbildung
zu machen ein Bildungsweg der ja lange
Zeit wenig populär war die Zeiten sind
aber
vorbei dann noch der Hinweis auf unser
heute journal Update nasin GK de mir
meldet sich hier um kurz vor Mitternacht
das war es auch von uns hier ist es
jetzt quasi auch vorbei machen sie es
gut wo auch immer sie sind
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend dieses Regenband zieht im
Laufe der Nacht weiter südwärts im Harz
kann auch mal etwas Schnee dabei sein
und in nordrinwestfalen setzt ergiebiger
Dauerregen ein bis Freitag früh können
60 bis 80 l Regen pro Quadratmeter
zusammenkommen in der Nordhälfte pfeift
dazu heute Nacht ein starker bis
stürmischer Wind aus westlichen
Richtungen unter den Regenwolken bleibt
die Nacht recht mild da sinken die Werte
auf 9 bis 7° kälter wird's im Süden bei
6 bis 0 und im Norden bei 6 bis 1° das
Regen und schneefallgebiet zieht morgen
ganz allmählich weiter südwärts dann
kann es auch im Sauerland im
nordhässischen Bergland im Thüringerwald
und im Erzgebirge für Schnee reichen
freundlicher bleibt es noch am Alpenrand
und auch hinter dem Regen werden sie
morgen hier in Norddeutschland häufiger
mal die Sonne zu Gesicht bekommen die
Temperaturen sinken von Norden und so
liegen sie morgen Abend in der
Nordosthälfte bei 0 bis 4° im Südwesten
ist es dagegen noch milder bei 7 bis 11°
und am Donnerstag kommt dann schon
gleich das nächste Tief hinterher es
bringt wieder Regen und Schnee mit in
der Nacht zu Freitag und Freitag früh
müssen wir uns also in schleswig-
Holstein und auch in Mecklenburg
Vorpommern auf Schnee einstellen dann
wird es glatt auf den Straßen deutlich
freundlicher wird dann der Samstag ich
will wün noch einen schönen
Abend